the award for best cinematography will
be presented by a young actress from
eastern europe
who's the star of gorky park and a man
who is a best actor nominee for his
first screen appearance
in a hat full of rain a girl from poland
a boy from manhattan
joanna pakula and anthony franciosa
nowadays the cinematographer or camera
person
has a world of sophisticated equipment
at his disposal
but it is still the individual who makes
the difference
between a picture that is merely a
photograph and a film that is a work of
art
and the nominees are sven nyquist
for fannie and alexander
don peterman for flash dance caleb de
chanel
for the right stuff
william a freaker for war games
and gordon willis for zelly
helena the moment is yours yes
and the winner is sven nyquist for kenny
and alexander
the time has come to thank
and i want to thank a man where
has the have had the fortune
to work with for about 25 years
on 22 pictures ingmar bergman
and i also want to thank the crew and
the actors
who have made my job so easy
and i want to make a special thanks to
the american cinematographers
who has been so nice to me and
in accepting and accepting me and my
work
thank you very much